[Music]
tonya is with us tonya is in new york
city hi tanya how are you
hi dave hi john
been listening to you guys since may
2020 thank the pandemic
i'm currently yes
i'm currently on baby step two
um with a student loan
six thousand dollars and car lease i
know don't hate me save uh six thousand
dollars i bring home 6500 a month
my car leaves in february 2023.
um i have a baby step three question
what do i do first do i save for the
three to six emergency fund or save for
my next car
three to six emergency fund
okay
okay the car the car upgrades and
couches and home purchases and vacations
and all those things are fine after you
have an emergency fund in place but if
you do those things without an emergency
fund in place you are inviting an
emergency
100 yeah you'll have it
yeah you're just kind of like looking at
the rain clouds going rain on me
taking all of your precious things in
the yard and saying you won't rain on me
[Laughter]
do it do it yeah just make sure you
finish the you know and so we stay
gazelle intense until we get through
baby step three thousand dollars in the
bank is one be debt free but the house
is baby step two emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses that's the
foundation that you build your life on
financially and so you stay very intense
very focused don't buy anything until
you get those three things done when
you've got those things done then you
save up and you get a better couch you
get a better car you get a better house
you get a better whatever it is um and
you're paying cash for the move up and
all of that of course so we don't go
back into debt
but that's exactly how that you move
from intensity to intentionality at that
point